schrecklicher fund in einem wohngebiet
in norderstedt einer kleinstadt in
schleswig holstein hier hinter mir wurde
am frühen morgen um kurz vor 4 einen
säugling gefunden ein männliches kind
das eingehüllt in eine blaue decke am
wegesrand einfach abgelegt wurde
die polizei begann sofort zu ermitteln
nachdem sich der finder des säuglings
gemeldet hatte und nun laufen die
ermittlungen wer die mutter des kindes
sein könnte denn die ist bislang
unbekannt
hinter mir ist im moment auch ein
spürhund im einsatz der versucht fährten
aufzunehmen um eventuell die spur der
mutter zu finden
ich würde hat mich dermaßen das können
sie gar nicht glauben das muss in der
heutigen zeit nicht sein
wir haben wir haben für die jungen
frauen die ungewollt schwanger sind oder
ein kind empfinden müssen da gibt es
babyklappen die türen anonym an den
krankenhäusern gebären und und wir
fühlten uns als bewohner auch sehr
sicher weil wir hier in norderstedt
denken das ist einigermaßen sicher und
das erschüttert ein als anwohner dass in
so einer straße so etwas heute noch
passiert in der nähe des gebüschs wo die
frau das kind entband entdeckten die
ermittler am samstagmorgen eine riesige
blutlache die polizei geht davon aus
dass durch den blutverlust die frau auf
dringende medizinische hilfe angewiesen
ist